I love you guys I'm Laura Ingram and
this is the Ingram angle from Washington
tonight the Trump DeSantis duel to come
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now how tiresome is commentary like this
but it's very important to expose him or
who he is which is not a regular
politician but a violent cult leader he
leads a powerful Cult of Personality a
Republican party that has become a cult
of personality around Donald Trump so
we're supposed to believe that Trump's
voters are only attracted to kind of is
in your face bare knuckle style like a
fighter who's refreshingly unwoke
well that's nonsense what his core
supporters firmly believe is that as of
now Trump is the only candidate who has
credibility on four vital policy issues
now Trump is a proven record of standing
up to China both Biden and the GOP
establishment want a partnership with
China
remember Trump ignored big business and
used tariffs to our advantage against
China Biden he's itching to remove him
we're not looking to decouple from China
we'd like to see this relationship get
on to a better footing a growing China
that plays by International rules is
good for the United States and the world
thank you Janet now Trump is opposed to
open borders both Biden and the GOP
establishment support open borders the
Biden Harris Administration announced
those sweeping measures that I mentioned
moments ago from the state and DHS to
expand legal Pathways launch Regional
process centers surge Asylum officers
and judges and more
she reads really well Trump is opposed
to never-ending Wars and wants to reform
our national security establishment
both Biden and the GOP establishment
support it and both have a record of
spending trillions and trillions on
failed Wars
and we will support you Ukraine's
defense for as long as it takes
supporting Ukraine as long as it takes
for as long as it takes that's how long
we're going to be with you Mr President
for as long as it takes
he was walking off the wrong side of the
stage all right Trump has proven record
of putting real conservatives on the
bench now Biden would put hard left
lunatics there and the GOP establishment
let's face it it has a record of
appointing folks like David Suter and
others like John Roberts
so that's four major issues issues that
should be critical in any election where
Trump right now has a clear policy
advantage over both Biden and the GOP
establishment and that all leads to the
following on domestic policy Trump has a
proven record of building an economy
that generated higher real wages for
American workers now neither the bite
Administration nor the old GOP guard can
say the same
and on social policy Trump led us to a
huge Victory to overturn Roe versus Wade
we know what the GOP establishment
failed to do yeah overturn Roe versus
Wade for only 40 years
and by the way Trump did all of this
while facing impeachment and the
fraudulent Mueller investigation
so simply attacking Trump as a person or
his style it's ain't gonna work
if you want to win the GOP nomination
you're going to have to convince the
voters that you're going to do the right
thing on China on the borders obviously
the economy on the military and judges
I I don't think that many people really
believe that Mike Pence Tim Scott Nikki
Haley would really be able to stand up
to the GOP establishment on any of those
issues so if you vote for them you're
effectively voting for Mitch McConnell
and almost no one in the GOP anymore
agrees with Mitch McConnell
so that leaves Ron DeSantis who
certainly has shown a willingness to
think for himself and to take positions
and to push policies that don't match up
with the GOP establishment he's taken on
the CCP by barring their land purchases
in a state he stood up to the corporate
worksters and he's built an impressive
diverse base of support
so tomorrow night when he announces it's
time for him to make his positions
crystal clear on the key issues where
Trump currently has a significant
advantage
now check out this head-to-head poll
if he does the right thing on those
issues well we could have a real horse
race could
if he thinks he can run As Trump light
I believe he's going to be disappointed
next summer we'll skip ahead a year
the GOP base wants its nominee to make
four big points at the convention
number one we will stand up to China
number two we will enforce our border
number three we will reform the National
Security State and number four you bet
we're going to appoint socially
conservative judges
they also want a candidate who's going
to campaign everywhere remember our
motto here on the Ingram angle no State
and no City left behind and that means
appeal to working people of all
backgrounds build a multicultural
majority
now for years Trump has been their only
option remember what Trump did to grow
Hispanic support and some
African-American support among black
males DeSantis changed the math with
Latinos in Miami-Dade County huge
turnaround there and now we're going to
see if he can replicate that elsewhere
so we hear that DeSantis is going to
announce his candidacy on Twitter with
Elon Musk I guess interviewing him
well last November musk endorsed
DeSantis but now he says he's neutral
and he just wants someone who's quote
normal as president I don't know what
that means you know people run for
president or and I guess are they normal
I don't know although musk is impressive
as we have said in many many ways he's
obviously a genius in many many ways his
neutrality is probably good news for
DeSantis given the fact that Tesla's
dependence on manufacturing and sales in
China could be an issue that Trump
brings up
but for anyone running on the GOP side
this has to be a campaign for America
not a campaign for the donors again
Trump's already proven his America First
bonafide's DeSantis still has work to do
he has a lot of people to convince
that's the way I see it tonight late May
2023.
and that's the angle